-Our next guest are sister
and authors of the new boo
"You'll Never Believe
What Happened to Lacey:
Crazy Stories About Racism,"
which is on sale tomorrow.
Please welcome to the show
Amber Ruffin and Lacey Lamar
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughs ]
-Hi! Oh, hello!
Oh. Hello. Hi. Ahh.
-Welcome, welcome.
-Oh, hi, Seth!
-Now, was this planned?
-Well, I had planned it.
[ Laughter ]
Lacey bought her dress, an
then I bought the same dress
and then I asked
for the same makeup and hair
-[ Laughter ]
-So...
-So, Lacey,
this is a sister of yours
who has her own television show.
She'll be on TV once a week.
-Whenever.
-Whenever. And yet here she goes
and steals your thunder.
-Steals my thunder.
-[ Laughing ]
-But you have a younger sibling,
so do you kind of know
what I'm going through?
-Although, right now
I'm growing my hair out
and stealing his thunder,
so I think -- I'm on your side
But thank you so much
for being here.
Amber, thank you
for coming down the hall.
So, I want to talk
about this book.
This is based on conversations
that you guys have as sisters.
How often do you two talk?
-All of the time.
-Every day. All the time.
-Yeah.
-Every time --
Text chains or phone calls
Is it both?
-It's all of it.
It's text chains.
Sometimes things
get really important,
and it's got to be FaceTime.
A text will not do.
Sometimes I don't want
to see her face, so I call her
-She gets angry when I call.
I want to call all the time,
and she doesn't.
-I have to see your face.
-Interesting. Interesting.
So, these are real-life storie
of racist incidents
that have happened to you.
I should stress -- because
there are a lot of books,
very important books about rac
right now.
This is a very true story,
and it's very troubling
to read it,
but it's also very humorous.
-Yes it is.
-Is that based on the fact
that when you guys
talk about these stories,
is there laughter involved
when you are relaying
these things to Amber?
-We laugh constantly,
and those stories are hilarious.
I mean, there's a bad side
to them, of course,
but when someone thinks
you look like Harriet Tubman..
-Yes.
You did -- There's a great story
in the beginning
about how you had
a Harriet Tubman check.
-She had
Black History Month checks
So, like, checks were, like...
[Laughing] Martin Luther Kin
and Marcus Garvey and stuff.
And then one of them
was Harriet Tubman.
She handed this child
a Harriet Tubman check,
and the cashier goes,
"Oh, I didn't know you could get
pictures of yourself on checks."
[ Laughs ]
And it's not a special picture
of Harriet Tubman
that you're not thinking of.
It's the picture
you're thinking of.
-It's the picture. Yeah.
-Ain't but two. It's that one.
-What -- It's not -- A lot o
these are workplace storie
and, like, things you've had t
endure as a professional.
And through all different kind
of jobs, it should be noted.
Is there someone particular --
If you could pick any one person
to read this book
or any one type of person,
who would it be?
-Um...people in workplaces
Supervisors. CEOs.
I've had to sit across fro
a CEO and have conversations
and they've blown my mind
with racist comments
that they've made.
So people that are, um,
running businesses,
that are in HR,
that think they know
how to talk to people of color
and they have no clue.
They need to take a look
at the book.
-I was shocked to find out
the HR stuff.
'Cause it's like -- "The call is
coming from inside the house."
It's HR. HR is doing it.
-Yes.
-There's a lot of --
HR does not --
Some people do not represent
themselves well in this book
but I'm wondering
as people you know back in Omaha
read this book,
do you think will they be able
to recognize themselves?
-They will -- Definitely.
They will remember the moment.
-Are there people
that you think are excited -
knowing you, are excited
to read the book not knowing
what's coming down the pike?
-I've had several of those
phone calls and texts.
"Lacey, I heard a book's
coming out. I am so excited.
And I'm like, "You're in there!"
[ Laughter ]
-Because, you know, one of the
sort of recurring themes her
is a lot of --
Now, again, there is
some very purposeful,
cruel racism in this book,
but there is a lot
that I think people
would be surprised to hear
the effect that it has on th
person they are speaking to.
-Definitely.
-And that I think is one of th
helpful things as a way --
Basically through this tim
we're living in,
it's, like, more people
have to be thoughtful
of, like,
how this is being heard
as opposed to how it's being
thought of as you're saying it
-Yeah. People aren't willing
to look at the effect it has
They're only willing
to look at, like,
"How culpable am I?
How bad did this make me look?
But that shouldn't
even be a part of it.
It should be...
"What am I doing to people
in the world?"
Lacey, did you want your drink
-Oh, of course. Thank you.
-I got a drink, too.
-Thank you so much.
-By the way,
I think it's very unfair
that they were served
in "Amber Ruffin Show" glasses
[ Laughter ]
-Turn it the right way.
-You better --
Drink that face-out.
-What about -- What about --
Your mother comes off
very well in this book
as someone who knows how to deal
with bad situations,
who stood up for her family.
You guys have two other sister
and a brother, as well.
As a very intelligent woman,
sort of a will not --
very no-nonsense.
Do you think she'll enjoy
reading the book?
-No.
-No. We will be in trouble
And she's gonna
watch this today,
and I am just gonna let her know
that that is all Amber's fault
-It is Amber's fault.
-100%.
-Mommy, Lacey did it.
I didn't do it!
-Mom, I didn't -- Save me.
-What will she not like
about it, though?
-Specifically
the stories about her.
-Right. Okay.
-Now, Mom is, like, super-smart.
She skipped second grade
and seventh grade.
She freakin'
is a little genius, but...
And she's handled everything
with grace.
But we chose...
-The Disneyland story.
We're gonna --
I'm gonna be grounded.
-We chose some bad stories
-And I'm a grown woman.
-Now, what happened? Tell us
about the Disneyland story
-No!
-No! I refuse.
-You got to buy the book?
-Buy the book.
-Ah, you got to buy the book
if you want to hear
about my mommy at Disneyland
-One nice thing that came out --
Again, I should say, like,
it's interesting to me
that you think
she will not like it
because a lot of nice things -
Your parents brought home books.
Right?
They really wanted their kid
to be readers,
and the kind of books
they brought home were often -
would lead to new hobbies,
new passions.
-Yeah. Down the street from us
was a book auction.
So every first Sunday
of the month,
they would go and just bid
on a lot of books,
which is just
a big box of books,
so they would be like, okay,
we have Stephen King's "It
and "Moby Dick"
and blah, blah, blah.
But then when
you got the book home,
there was 50 books in there.
So then, like, at the bottom
is, like, "Intro to Sailing"
and stuff.
And so anything -- It just
built up quite the library
So any hobby you could think of,
we already had a book about it
Like, I ended up doing mosaics
and learning Sign Language
-I was all about gems and rocks.
-Gems and rocks.
-Yeah, just because
this thing was down the street
It's in the house.
It's the '80s.
We are bored.
-[ Laughs ] Gems and rocks
Hey, before we go,
it's been so lovely
to have you both out together,
but let's wish Amber --
'Cause Amber doesn't get
enough attention, Lacey.
I do want to make sure we pay --
-I understand.
-Amber's birthday on Saturday.
Happy birthday, Amber!
-Whoo! Happy birthday!
-I turned 27!
-And you're her older sister
by a year.
-♪♪ Twenty eight ♪♪
-Oh, my God. Thank you guys both
for being here.
This book is -- I want to stress
how very funny it is.
-[ Giggling ]
-Oh, yeah. This is pointless
It's just in one ear...
If she thinks
she's on her single,
she doesn't listen
to a word I say.
"You'll Never Believe
What Happened to Lacey"
is available tomorrow
wherever you buy your books,
but, please, support local
and independent bookstores
We'll be right back with
the music of Future Islands.